good afternoon and welcome to the world
leaders forum I want to thank the
Institute of African Studies for
co-sponsoring this event today and
professor Sullivan Basheer down for
moderating the question and answer
session that will occur at the end of
this program this is a great opportunity
the world leaders forum and our guest
today for all of us to try to think
understand better the challenges around
the world we see these challenges in a
damaged economy and a dysfunctional
financial system in many ways which has
created deep layers of instability that
will require years of recovery we see
the challenges of globalization that has
improved millions of lives but also
sharply increase the income gap between
the wealthy and almost everyone else and
we see these challenges and the
remarkable communications and Technology
revolutions that have at once made our
world so small that we can readily reach
across vast distances and we see these
challenges in a world that faces
profound threats to sustainable
development due to climate change and
environmental degradation today we will
be hearing from one of our great world
leaders Nobel laureate Her Excellency
Madame Ellen Johnson Sirleaf president
of the Republic of Liberia Madame
Johnson Sirleaf we all welcome you here
to New York and to Columbia University
Liberia's fierce challenges are perhaps
more daunting than most it is a nation
still recovering from decades of brutal
civil wars that decimated the population
and the economy
it is a nation with rich natural
resources that have too often provided
as they have in so many countries
opportunities for exploitation rather
than for growth and opportunities for
all citizens to these challenges
President Johnson Sirleaf now in her
second term brings her remarkable
personal attributes and career
experiences a student of economics and
accounting she studied in both Africa
and here in the United States where she
earned a master's in public
administration from Harvard's Kennedy
School she served as her nations
Minister of Finance more than three
decades ago before pursuing an
accomplished career in both the private
sector and as a senior official at the
World Bank during the period of
dictatorship in civil war she was forced
into exile in the Ivory Coast later
returning to Liberia to lead the
nation's governance reform commission
with her victory in the 2005 democratic
elections the president became the first
elected female head of state in Africa
her agenda in office has included
securing forgiveness for billions of
dollars of Liberian debt signing into
law a Freedom of Information bill the
first of its kind in West Africa in
establishing a Truth and Reconciliation
Commission to investigate and address
the continuing consequences from decades
of civil strife and populating her
cabinet with a significant number of
women well it has not been an easy path
Liberia has also seen increasing
economic growth from foreign investments
and improving trade and from its role as
the second largest maritime licensure in
the world this week at the UN General
Assembly she is joining the President of
India
Asia and the Prime Minister of Britain
on a panel that has been convened to set
up the post 2015 International
Development Agenda to follow the current
Millennium Development Goals the Nobel
Prize Committee recognized her lifetime
of courageous accomplishments when they
awarded her the Peace Prize this past
year for nonviolent struggle for the
safety of women and for women's rights
to full participation in peace building
work it is therefore a special honor for
us to welcome to Colombia Her Excellency
Madame Ellen Johnson Sirleaf president
of the Republic of Liberia
president Boehm go members of the Board
of Trustees faculty administrators
students distinguished guests my
compatriots here ladies and gentlemen I
want you to know that the reputation of
Columbia School sessions like this
precede you the activism that you show
in these meetings were very well aware
of so I'm looking forward to that
interactive session once I've completed
my statement let me first introduce to
you those who are with me they're part
of our delegation our senior senator Chu
of our Taylor
Minister of Justice Cristiano da
many stuff planning and finance
americani chief of protocol David
Anderson director of communication
Shirley Brownell many self-education
ever the Minister of Information culture
fed tourism and the deputy protocol
officer
right back of them as an assistant
minister of information as the press
secretary those are independent press
people will bring you greetings from the
government and people of Liberia I'd
like to thank you for this opportunity
to be here have you invited me to speak
about Liberia less than a decade ago
our discussion would have centered on
what is today described as a failed
state as recently as 2003 our country
was the poster child of failed statehood
having reached the point where Liberians
traveling abroad were ashamed to carry
our passport today thanks to the
resilience of our people their hard work
and our commitment to move forward
Liberia has turned the corner to get to
where we were today we received much
appreciated support from the
international community and labeling us
to embark upon the transformative agenda
that is now underway looking at our own
recent history the topic of the
conversation today is how do you move
from a failed state to a fragile state
and from a fragile state to a
competitive state in the process of
transformation as you well know if
failed state is one where governing
mechanisms which provide the well-being
of the people have broken down the
security apparatus meant to protect them
is this
functional the economy's at the mercy of
predators and social services have
crumbled that's where we were the
transformative process for Liberia
started with the Arab Peace Accord in
2003 we had been three years of a
transition a transition period of mixed
results successful in maintaining the
peace in starting the operation of
institutions but hardly moving the
country much for much further because of
the interplay of those that were part of
the transition representing those that
came from different factions all having
to collaborate to be able to move toward
a modern state we from the transition
when this administration came into power
in January 2006 we started what we call
the period of stabilization and one of
the key things we did was to establish
four pillars under the poverty reduction
strategy the pillars were peace
stability economic reconstruction
governance in a rule of law
infrastructure and basic services
another piece of security sector we had
to deal with an army that largely
comprised people from different warring
factions
and so it meant disbanding the entire
army starting all over
setting admission criteria we should
enable we should allow only those with a
certain level of education with the
support of the u.s. that process has now
produced two thousand well trained
professional new army it also meant the
rest of the security sector such as the
police the immigration and others
putting them through rigid training
programs to enable them to prepare
themselves to protect the security of
the state at the same time we had a
peacekeeping force a UN peacekeeping
force one of the highest in the world at
the time fourteen thousand today down to
seven thousand and in the period of
drawdown which within three to five
years we'll see them depart and at that
time hopefully were in the position and
have a capacity to take it or ourselves
under economic revitalization being a
resource rich country natural resource
rich country with the mining agriculture
forestry fishing potential we went for
mobilizing private capital our own
resources being limited on we were able
to mobilize some 16 billion in foreign
direct investment in all of these
sectors operations which are just
getting started with the results would
be seeing putting our fiscal regime in
order ensuring that we had we subscribe
to a balanced budget a cash based budget
so that we would not
have these huge fiscal deficits and the
results that they bring in inflation we
enter the hypocritic program we were
able in what we call a record time of
about three years to cancel essentially
a four point nine billion external debt
that had not been served for twenty
years making sure that we then open up
the economy required the infrastructure
that it takes to make them move and so
schools clinics roads electricity water
system all of those things lacking in
terms of public service were things that
we got started institutions governance
and the rule of law just building those
basic institutions with a capacity
constraint that was face getting those
dysfunctional institution working again
some of the things we had to do law
reform over the years duplicate of laws
complicated laws laws that require
amendments repeals to bring them to
current conditions were were things that
we had to do as I mentioned
institutional development the capacity
issue because most of those stream had
left the country over the years the
brain dream had affected these
institutions as a matter of fact the
concentration of power in the center the
concentration the presidency that was so
domineering
that we have to build the institution so
that you could be able to move some of
that power and decision-making away from
the center which was ruling by Fiat
ruling by discretion the pillars of
integrity that meant strengthening our
governance our auditing Commission
general auditing Commission which we
move to do creating a anti-corruption
Commission we subscribe to the
extractive industry transparency
initiative and I'm proud to say that we
were one of the would one of the first
African country to become compliant
under that just developing policies
formulating the strategy and policies in
all of our sector that would guide us
toward our agenda rebuilding our
relationships relationships with our
labor as you know in those es of war
Liberia was the epic center of a
regional war and so mending fences with
our neighbors became very important
renewing getting our bilateral and
multilateral institutions and
relationships back so that we could
having solved the debt problem having
built the institution's haven't set the
policies we had access to the normal
facilities that countries would have our
diplomatic relations with our
international relationship with
international organisations all broken
down over those years meant fixing those
at the end of the six years we conclude
that our stabilization period is in
place Liberia's growth rate for the past
six years has averaged 6.5 percent this
year 2012 the estimates of the IMF is
that it would be eight point eight
percent
and that's not enough we know that but
that's where we are and our institutions
are functioning again
capacity is growing so now we enter the
period that we call truly the
transformation period and what does our
trans transformative agenda consists of
in the first instance and we give credit
to our Minister here who led this effort
is to develop a long term perspective a
development agenda that goes beyond the
normal cycle and so we've we've already
formulated what is called vision 2030 by
the year 2030 this is what we want to
achieve and that particular ultimate
goal is to become a middle-income
country by that year to do so means he
was also taken to account what people in
the country want not a desktop review
and formulation of a vision but because
for too long people have been left out
of the process of formulating their
vision this requires a two year process
of robust consultation all over the
country down down into the community
levels where one begins to see this also
required in formulating this vision
determining what were the root causes of
the problems that we face why did we
generate into Wars why are we not able
to sustain our development given the
fact that we are so natural resource
rich that agenda that low vision
attempts to go into that and to describe
it and it comes from the people
themselves their own views or what the
problem is and what the solutions ought
to be
we have now gone from an annual budget
cycle to a medium-term expenditure
framework and under that it enables us
to continue to mobilize private capital
private investment to ship resources
from recurrent to investment because you
now have a longer time framework when
that investment you know will there will
be sufficient budgetary allocation to be
able to complete investment that may
cover more than a period of a year
infrastructure one of our major
constraints and those basic economic
infrastructure that makes a difference
in whether you continue to reach your
targets power today the country with 21
megawatts of power resulting in the cost
of electricity at over 50 cents per
kilowatt hour you can imagine compare
that will say hydropower whoever cost is
about 7 cents per kilowatt hour you can
see the big gap that is so part of that
transformative thing is to put in is to
rehabilitate our hydro plant to be able
to examine alternative sources of energy
what a solar or windmill or biomass all
of those possibilities of trying to do
that our road system we're in the rain
forest where the capital costs of
building roads are so high and they're
only limited period when construction
can take place because for six months we
have rains and today climate change the
effects of climate change are real we
feel it because farming patterns are
changing the rains are excessively heavy
so we have to think of how do we how do
we address that and not forgetting the
fact that social infrastructure also
important education for so many years
many of our young people will bypass by
education
many of them were child soldiers who all
they knew was how how to destroy how to
kill today as we go into the tenth year
of peace you can see their
transformation in there but you can also
see the anxiety in them sometimes even
the anger in them that they've been
bypassed that they're part of a lost
generation and how does one respond to
their needs very quickly before that
dissatisfaction turns into and so
education some of them too old for that
skills training vocational training to
enable them to have the means whereby
they can have a livelihood and so you've
development is part of this new
transformative agenda how do we put them
to work how do we manage their race
expectations how do we transform them
into productive creative contributing
students I mentioned capacity and I'll
come back to that there's so many things
so many achievement that could have been
much more but for our own limitations of
capacity we have tremendous support from
partners but we we can't let them do it
for us
completely technical assistance yes
training yes but we've got to be able to
do it ourselves and that means that
there will be limitations in the
achievement in the success in the
results as we begin our own people begin
to learn to take on the responsibilities
of getting things done so we have lots
of special programs to deal with with
the capacity issue we had support for
example from the Open Society initiative
the topping off of salaries for a
certain period of time to enable us to
repatriate professional capable
Liberians from the diaspora and Bri
them home to take this responsibility
getting scholarship programs ourselves
some of it coming from universities like
Columbia and others where we're training
people in specialized skills but at the
same time building our own institutions
which is the real answer and getting
that quality education at all levels we
started with the lower levels we made
primary education free we extended it to
middle school in public in public
schools free and compulsory and it's
starting to work but it's still lower
because mothers still send their
children to sell on the streets because
that's how they survive or take them to
the farms to help them to drive the
birds from the rice farms because that's
how they that's what they are accustomed
to how do we change how do we change all
of that we've got what we call the
president's young professional program
bringing the young graduates from the
University and putting them under
mentoring programs with some of our
professionals so that they be able to
grow in their professions all of those
are part of the combination of trying to
address that reconciliation the many
years of starting from our 1980 coup
d'etat to the Wars and the different
warring factions and the different
political competitions and strife makes
reconciliation image how do we reach
that cross that bridge it's not it's not
today it starts from a cleavage that
started from our very beginnings when
you had emancipated slaves go back to
our country and met with indigenous
population and refused to give them the
same kind of equality and so that
cleavage that bridge that started way
bare has never really been resolved and
has come today came to the place where
it manifested itself in a coup d'etat
and that coup d'etat itself did not
solve it and so that transformed into a
war and the war brought more factions
more divisions so we have we want to
tackle that reconciliate
we've been working on a road map for
that a road map that's going to be
validated by the public along with the
efficient 2030 early November when those
two documents having already come from a
robust process of consultation with
people will be even validated we hope by
a larger group of people coming together
in what we hope will be a national
conference to be able to look at at
those particular issues part of the
transformation judicial reform they our
judicial system patterned after the
United States in every way
most of our laws and our statues
patterned after United our Constitution
is going to be constitutional review
because they've got cycling cycling
elements in the Constitution that are
totally incompatible with today's
requirements discriminatory clauses that
have been in there how do we make sure
that you know with that we can begin to
to deal with the judiciary government
rationalization we've got two bigger
government and and we've got to be able
to to slim down the government the
public the government must do only those
things required of government so that
the private sector can be placed at the
center of our of our growth agenda and
so that's concessions review I'm quite
sure many of you have read at this 16
billion we talk about a lot of them have
brought problems of land land reform
because we've given large tracts of land
to mining concessions to agriculture
concessions but it hasn't worked very
well because we now have a community
rights law in which we say communities
have the right to their land and
communities rights must be protected so
you have this this contradictory thing
of that we have to sort of or how do we
ensure that we bring in the investment
because they create the investment
brings infrastructure development
investment brings job the investment
brings per-capita income increases but
at the same time
I make sure that the rights of the
community is protected so that their
farming system are in place the oil
sector I'm sure many people know that
Liberia today prospecting for oil we
won't see a drop of oil in my
administration thank God so I won't have
to deal with that but if we do not take
the measures that protect future
generations then we stand a chance that
Liberia to become a nation with a
resource curse and so we must make sure
that we put in the structures the laws
the systems we must use the example of
other countries that have done it well
that have made sure that these resources
indeed translate into programs that
benefit the majority of the people and
that they are secured for future
generation is seam apply to our forestry
sector and so and finally how do we
change the mindset I call it value
system reordering that I think is the
most difficult part of all young people
old people subjected to deprivation for
a period of two decades who has survived
nearly by their wits any way they could
whether it was a resort to extortion or
a resort to violence or resort resort to
this honesty the hetero survival was a
survival mentality and that affects the
mindset of people how do we change that
so that everybody becomes the owner of
their own society the protector of their
destiny that they indeed can determine
their fate and know that their country
only moves by their participation by
their ownership by their contribution
that's the biggest of it the moral
rearmament is something that I don't
have any answer to we look to others the
social scientists and others who who can
help to deal with that but we still see
with all the challenges with all the
progress Liberia still remains today a
nation of hope and if that's anything
that we've been able to accomplish is to
have given our people hope hope for the
future the promise of a better life the
promise that indeed tomorrow they can be
what they want to be on the basis of
their own industry and their
contribution we are determined that in
10 years
Liberia will not have to tap to take
foreign aid that we can do it on the
basis our resources we are determined
when I talk about a 2030 vision that
come the year 2030 who will be a
middle-income country that's our
commitment to our people
that's how people's commitment to
themselves thank you for the opportunity
thank you
good afternoon my name is Suleiman
Bashir yang I'm a professor in the
department's of French and Philosophy
and I'm the acting director of the
Institute of African Studies and it is a
great honor for me to be moderator of
this Q&A session and it gives me the
opportunity your excellency - thank you
very much for a wonderful talk and thank
you you have ended your speech on the
word hope we want to thank you on behalf
of all the africanist community all the
many African scholars our Africa here at
Columbia and the Colombian community at
large - thank you for representing
indeed hope yourself and representing
Africa as a continent of hope and not
anymore as a basket case
Madam President has indicated how eager
she is to engage the Columbia community
in particular our vibrant community of
undergraduate students so you are
invited to use these microphones on both
aisles and please line up behind those
microphones and ask your questions
allowing the maximum interaction for
this for this session and do not forget
please to introduce yourself when you
ask your question so I will start with
my right please your excellency excuse
me your excellency thank you so much for
coming here to Columbia University
myself and four other researchers from
the School of International Affairs
spent this last summer in Liberia we
really really enjoyed your beautiful
country and it's great people so thank
you so we did a lot of research on the
forestry sector and how that impacts
governance and as you're aware of I know
there's a lot of problems with that so
my question to you your excellency is
how how do you see this transition until
communities actually in the rural
communities actually become empowered
because we know at this point the
companies that are operating are pretty
pretty shady companies that would not be
operating in most of the world I do
understand the need to collect revenues
on to attract investment but how do you
how do you get to that point where you
can actually have a rural community that
is being treated responsibly by
companies I understand that there's a
gap there's a bridge to be crossed to
get to that point but how do you get to
that point
thank you very well maybe I should take
a couple as a one-by-one
okay let me deal with this one because
then somebody else may not acts that'll
carry that forward I can I can deal with
it you no doubt referring to the recent
Global Witness report that that has to
do with what was what is called the
private use permit in our forestry
sector this is what happens when a good
intent gets turned around
we gave concessions because we have
forestry poppin public land where we
know that we have to preserve it so we
have a forestry law that has to do with
commercialization conservatism and
community benefits we also passed a
community benefit law in which those
communities that have forests in depth
in their areas can benefit by having
logging operations but do not have to
meet the taxing and other requirement
thereby enabling them to use the
resources to build their communities but
where we both went wrong was that we did
not build a capacity in the communities
for them to understand those rights
properly and to be able to protect
themselves so some of the major large
companies who had to operate it for them
simply compromised some of the local
leaders took large tracts of their
forest land give them small compensation
in return and thereby bypass the
regulations which was meant for use of
the communities also tax evasion
because we did not subject it and so we
now have to review though the whole
forestry sector the concessions that
were given to see if somebody has
willfully compromised our community
leaders will prolly bypass our laws in
which case action we have to be taken I
don't know what course of action where
is where is concession cancellation or
concession revision or renegotiations
that we have to be tickity determined
from the findings of an independent
group that has been established to look
into that problem now are these
companies what do you call them shady
companies
so global witnesses but when we when we
we negotiated with concessions we use
the International Law Group a group of
lawyers from this country to work with
us to make sure that they would help but
if they are shaded we'll unshaded
thank you I now move to the next
question please hello my name is Karina
juga I'm studying human rights here at
Columbia and Madam President Sirleaf I
would really like to thank you for
taking the time to address us here at
Columbia today and I would like to ask
what steps Liberia is taking to advance
education for girls okay maybe I'll take
two mo yes my name is Erin O'Reilly and
I'm a student of development practice at
supa I was also lucky enough to conduct
research in Liberia last year working
with communities in Grand Cape Mount in
barkuloo County and I hate to bring her
back to concessions but we were looking
at the impact of the sim derby palm oil
plantation on food security and
agriculture in those communities and we
had determined that in the areas where
the palm oil had already been or the
palm trees had already been planted
there had been a visible impact on the
agriculture and the land available to
those communities and we know that the
government is working on this issue
right now and that the interagency task
force has recognized that perhaps free
and prior informed consent and proper
surveying of the communities ahead of
the development maybe was not conducted
in the right manner my question is is
now that these things have been
determined and the process is moving
forward how will the government work
with the communities that are already
being touched by the development will
there be any adjustment of the
compensation that they could receive for
land that was taken from them even
though they've already received some
compensation for the crops that was on
that land when the land was taken by the
company and how will the government
address the current food insecurity in
these communities because there is no
outlet for them no other land and no
outdoor program provided by the company
the moment one mode then we'll get to
answer step 1
hi Julian Hector engineering class of
2010 and I was able to go to Sierra
Leone in 2007 one of the things that
really struck me was that there you know
similarly similarly to Liberia there is
a lack of electricity but at the same
time when I was in Freetown I was on a
house overlooking a hill and there was
so much breeze blowing and it made me
think of how in Jamaica we've
successfully implemented wind projects
could you comment on the plausibility of
doing something like that in Liberia
possibly using carbon offsets with other
nations girls education that is a clear
priority of arc I've been recognizing
that the world over girls education have
not been given the priority like boys
particularly in poor nations when
household income is not sufficient the
boys get the first chance of an
education and the girls get left behind
and so our enforcement of compulsory
primary education in public schools
brought a quadrupling of of enrolment
and a majority our girls because they
were the ones that were being left
behind our problem when it comes to
girls education is retention once they
get past primary into secondary school
then teenage pregnancy other kinds of
diversion from school is where our
challenge is and what we're trying to to
look at what has happened in other
places to reduce this as a matter of
fact I just saw that that's a problem
even here today in this country I was
saying so
you know we're we're trying to deal with
that but we've done you know school
lunches free uniforms we've tried all of
that as a means of of encouraging the
parents to send their children to school
even as an innovative program that has
started in one County cash transfers
just giving cash transfers let's say to
grandmother's who take care of their
children - and then it's tie - they're
keeping the kids in school so it is a
priority for us the signed Derby
experience is a troubling one and I
guess you correctly pointed out that
matter is being addressed through this
interagency task force we if land has to
be retrieved or relinquished by cell
job' to return some of them to the
communities that will be done we we must
find a way to balance the protection of
the community and giving them their
rights for their farming activities to
ensure food security but at the same
time making sure that an investment in
the greater part of the land that we
indeed produce benefits for the
community housing benefits job benefits
social infrastructure benefits is
finding the right balance and I think if
there's any era we made it was not to
have had the proper communication with
the community before so that they know
this is the land this is what will go
toward industrial production this is
what will be routine so we trying to
correct that after the fact so you oh
you did the that studies no notice our
papers should become
shortly all right okay electricity we're
we're looking at alternative sources of
electricity and the most favorite
alternative for us quite frankly many
hydros Liberia is a country full of
water bodies and hydro is still the most
economical solar lights we're looking at
windmills our possibility biomass all of
those we've got an entity now really
like electrification institution
organization that is now undertaking the
study on alternative sources of energy
so that we might be able to apply those
as we move from thermal generation even
with the reconstruction of the hydro
will not have enough electricity for a
rural area so we have to find
alternatives out there we'll be glad to
look at it Jamaica experience thank you
good afternoon madam president thank you
for giving us the opportunity to ask you
some questions this afternoon my name is
Elizabeth Farah and my master's and
development practice as well as Erin at
supa and I was on the team of four that
traveled to Liberia in the spring to
measure food security in the palm oil
area and as an economist I'm sure you
know that Liberia is food insecure
sensitive and highly vulnerable to
increases in spikes and food and fuel
prices particularly rice which is
Liberia's staple as Erin mentioned our
findings through our research project on
the ground found that the area that was
under cultivation had experienced a
decrease in food security and an
increase in vulnerability in the areas
that were under cultivation and I was
wondering what interventions is the
government working on to smooth the
impact of food prices and shops expected
in the near future
particularly in the
during the duration of the time that the
palm oil trees are under gestation which
is for the next three to five years and
unemployment is much lower than will be
in over the next couple of years as well
as the increase to migration for the
area for people looking for jobs which
creates a higher demand on food prices
which again enhances the shock of
increases on food prices and yeah and so
in kids sorry one last bit so
considering that Liberia is food
insecure primarily because there's a
high imports of foods and world market
prices are expect to increase with
respect to race in particular thank you
the people of Harlem are food insecure
know that stuff such as a bun that's
just upon you are absolutely correct
that the prices of food worldwide will
increase as a result of the climate
conditions all over the world and we
know that our staple rice and other
staples other pulses will also face
price increases what we're doing is
trying to now stress agriculture
agriculture with a focus on small
farmers try to get people back into the
land back into farming part of the
problem was the migration during the
many years of war today the capital city
bursting and it seems is hosting
one-third of the population of the
country because they all went there for
safety but to get them back you have to
have the incentives they have to have
the land land is not enough they have to
have assistance to do farming tools
seeds you know helping them with finding
markets so our agriculture program in
fact there is a USA program as you know
that's now supporting food food security
truly support for small farmers like
is a member of that a beneficiary of
that program and we will be stressing
with stressing that so it's a problem
you absolutely right we're trying to
find the solution to it by putting more
support into small-scale agriculture so
Madam President one last round of three
and then you will be invited to give
concluding remarks as well so please go
ahead
thank you good afternoon madam president
my name is Bruno Mendez and I'm a
third-year student at Columbia College
you mentioned that I'm sorry I don't get
to speak to authorities all the time so
I'm a little bit nervous I'm nervous too
so yeah so you mentioned that it's it's
important for the government to remain
as slim as possible and be responsible
for making government functions while
giving enough space for the private
sector to foster effective growth but um
I think another widely agreed upon
concern of development is inequality so
given these two factors what would you
say are the most effective ways for the
government to foster equitable growth
without growing too much I guess
inequality yes there is some of that you
still have in our society the pyramid in
which the bottom half most of the people
the poor we have to true equal
opportunity through training begin to
try to close that gap between the haves
and the have-nots I think it's a
challenge for for all societies even
even this one to be able to promote
equality because they will they will all
there will always be a certain amount of
inequality based upon people's chosen
path
people's desire people's giving
commitment to education to training to
working but as a government we have a
responsibility to make sure that our
laws our policies our practices provide
equal opportunity to all and for the
most vulnerable ensure that all there
are social safety nets and transfers to
be able to give them an opportunity to
live so it's an ongoing continuing
process of trying to address income
inequalities of fertility inequalities
in every society and ours is no
exception
good afternoon Madam President my name
is Mohammed Keita I'm currently with the
Committee to Protect Journalists and I
imagine you can guess the direction of
my question but I wanted to ask how can
your government enhance its support for
civil society in Liberia especially when
it comes to human rights defenders
journalists and others whose work may at
times exposed the shortfalls of
government I'm specifically talking
about when journalists human rights
defenders become threatened and what the
government can do to improve the
enforcement of the rule of law and to
deliver justice not only for them but
also for the most vulnerable in Liberia
I was troubled a few months ago to read
that Liberian reporter had to go into
hiding because she received little
assistance from the police and she was
essentially on her own only because she
had reported about the practice of
female genital mutilation you know I
understand that it's a very politically
sensitive topic in Liberia and that it's
a widespread practice
especially that is practiced by the
powerful secret societies but I also
understand that the government licenses
this practice or regulates this practice
so what sorts of resources in terms of
capital or political will that your
government need in terms of improving
its support for the work of journalists
you know journalists like mayors angle
we are proud of Liberia's record on the
rule of law and on the promotion of
freedoms freedom of the media freedom
all freedoms religion association
expression we're the only country to
have signed a Freedom of Information Act
we've already attested to the Table
Mountain declaration and our media is as
free as they come despite the fact that
our Constitution says freedom carries
with it responsibility responsibility
for what you do and what you say but our
press is very free I make a pact with
you if you can tell me how we can have a
group to protect people from
irresponsible media reporting then we'll
be fair in protecting the Mayers angle
story all she needed to do was to have
gone to our Ministry of Justice and say
we have a case of somebody threatening
my life even if she said I did not know
we have intelligence today we're
breaking a case right in Liberia where
our intelligence have found people in a
phone call trying to take
Ransome we would have found that person
but to get on the internet and charge
something that you have not
substantiated because you want to come
to America it's a dangerous thing
and so I say our media is free there's
nobody being prosecuted for any freedom
of expression or any story they attack
me they attack official they attack the
attack the attack ambassadors sometimes
unjustifiably but there's no recourse
against them but there are some stories
that in fact are simply untrue men to
serve personal purposes we also need a
protection of people who face defamation
and false accusation because of personal
interests may I invite you Madam
President to have one last question and
then make closing remarks good afternoon
madam president my name is Chris Van
hise I'm a postback pre-medical student
and my question is um how do you uh how
do you establish a respect for human
rights and a code in a country that has
developed a culture of impunity
thank you you pass laws you create
institutions to fight that impunity
that's why we have an independent Human
Rights Commission where they can take
any action against somebody impunity is
a long-standing thing in our societies
and in others we continue to fight it
and address it you can take anybody to
court we encourage it we encourage it
through our private lawyers are true we
do have public defenders to help those
who who don't have the means to be able
to hire their lawyers our Ministry of
Justice the
mr. herself is a son of a human rights
activist herself you know in her in her
in her days of teaching in this place
she has the sea mines act like you so
you can be sure that she is going to to
protect the rights of people so we just
have to develop the laws the policies
the institutions and is something to be
able to fight the infinity thank you can
I do more yes one more no I wanted him
to know maybe he could tell me what else
I can do the fighting the air all right
no just just one more yes your
excellency
thank you so much for coming here and
taking corrections from the audience my
name is Elijah Sangha and I'm from
Gambia my question is more of a general
question regarding West Africa again I'm
from Gambia and Gambia like in most
other West African countries there is no
democracy and we have a head of state
that just recently executed nine
prisoners I'm so most of the most of the
audience here have had it on the news
and my question to you is what will you
tell Gambians and other people in the
West Africa who are living in the
oppressing a government that is
oppressing them what will be your
message if you have to go to there today
and to uplift them or you tell them we
have our regional protocols Economic
Community of West African states have
protocols to which all of us have
subscribed regarding the protection of
the rights of the individual regarding
democracy some were respected for laymen
maybe some well not respected fully but
those are the protocols and we go to our
regional meetings and we talk about
those protocols and we urge all Member
States
to make sure that they subscribe to that
and when there's a major departure as in
the case of Molly attempting to take us
back to the days of carita our position
on that was very firm and very strong
that anyone that foul is the rights of
others will not have the same rights in
our community so that's my response
we'll take it up in our next summit
meeting thank you madam president you've
been very generous with us we would have
kept you all evening and we are sure you
would have had the generosity of staying
with us but may I invite you to a couple
of concluding remarks and we will miss
everybody finish unfortunately I don't
mind answering their questions quite
frankly Oh
I am now the line got longer thank you
so much Madam President I'll actually
have a solution of moral rearmament you
mentioned and I'll mention at the end of
my remark I remember you want our
interviews you mentioned that what a
woman can bring to the process of
rebuilding a fragile state it is extra
sensitivity and more caring comes from
the characteristic of being a mother
taking care of the family being being
concerned by the children and also
managing the home I have seen Liberian
women have been playing very extremely
significant role ever since the
beginning of peace process and what I
want to say is a half a world away a
very precious mother named Jeong Georgia
started a movement of spreading mother's
love and she's turned nothing to help
people around her and devoted everything
without expecting anything in return and
her effort throughout the decades
inspired millions of youth across the
globe to devote themselves to help
people around them and here yourself
having is a mother and I like we all
have seen you managing successfully
managing your own household and Liberia
as a nation so and you have this
mandatory program sending all the
children to school and you also
integrate the former opposition parties
into your cabinet which is phenomenal so
actually this reminds me of one
paragraph in the Bible first Corinthians
chapter 13 if you replace the love with
mother it makes perfect sense I would
just really really quick mother keeps no
record of wrongs mother does not delight
in evil but rejoices with the truth
mother always protects always trusts
always hopes always perseveres mother
never fails so I couldn't agree with you
more
so in my opinion mother's love is the
moral rig is a social of modern moral
rearmament because only a mother can
unconditionally sacrificing herself for
other people only for the benefit of
people wronged her and this is message I
want to deliver from jung-gil Jeanine
her she is a she's a chairwoman of
international we love you Foundation and
my name is su Hyun who and from Limoges
go up arts and sciences in Colombia I'm
a human rights major thank you so much
thank you like I say I agree with you
completely everything you say you're so
right let me consider that this is an
excellent counterpoint to hope madam
president can we do two last one I'll
let you select impudence indeed it is so
we will have two last questions please
thank you so much madam president it's
an honor to be here today and to hear
you
my name is Frida Austin I am a student
at the school of international public
affairs I'm also part of the cpap an
African Network I love to hear you say
that we are looking long term you're
looking at there 2030 agenda and one of
the things that concerns us and we're
having an upcoming diplomatic forum in
November is statecraft and I think you
are almost an epitome of how to do that
and well but looking the long term what
strategically are you doing to position
Liberia on the international stage as a
high middle-income country what are you
doing - put Liberia at a place where is
able to receive the resources that are
coming in and use it as a leverage for
its people so there's a lot of foreign
direct investment I hear you say but
what are you how are you going to
translate that and how are you going to
put Liberia on the stage and may prepare
it to become a middle
although many things that I mentioned
building capacity through education and
trimming building the institutions
ensuring that our our laws policies our
strategies all not only strength good
but growth with equity sustainable
development those are all part of that
agenda the details are carried in our in
our new vision I mentioned only the
broad objective but the details are
backed up by all of these programs sorry
I meant
and your interactions on the
international stage with other world
leaders for instance we know there are
no African countries in the OECD so as
you are making those rounds in the
international stage how do you prepare
Liberia I think we're there already you
don't think so
leave that to you I think Liberia was
just chosen as one of the a was
mentioned by the president one of the
one of the three countries I represented
my period I will be formulating the
successor regime to the Millennium
Development Goals what we call the
post-2015 development agenda I think
that in itself is a recognition of the
role we will play in the world and so I
think in that respect where we're
already there in our region we're known
to be one of the leaders supportive of
the transformation economic
transformation a democratic process so
we'll try to meet your expectations
your excellency it's an honor to address
you and also was the last question of
this afternoon
my name is Nikolai I'm studying master's
program in climate society at Columbia
my question is in relation to your new
position on the UN Secretary General's
high-level advisory board for the
post-2015 International Development
agenda
it would be very interesting to hear
your perspective on how important the
Millennium Development Goals have really
been for progress and transition in
Liberia and also your your views on the
role of sustainable development targets
in the post-2015 agenda given the Rio
+20 summit and discussion that we made
there where one did not reach a set of
sustainable development goals as many
had hoped so both personal reflections
and those of the high-level advisory
group when you convened here in New York
would be very interesting thank you
because the MDGs were formulated without
widespread people consultation and
participation it was only in the latter
years that countries began to really
really focus on it particularly
countries in Africa where the capacity
is limited what are the lack of
statistics and data to be able to
measure performance or insufficient
that's why today the the MDGs are just
three years from coming to the final
point many of our countries are not
going to meet all the goals one or two
will one or two will meet some of them
but in terms of all it goals being met
by all of our countries that's not going
to happen and we know it the post-2015
group first of all has to look at the
MDGs what's the progress today what has
been the reason why many countries have
not been able to meet them how can we
accelerate the effort in the next three
years so we don't take our eye off the
MDG ball but we try to accelerate to see
at many
can go through and achieve as many of
them as possible but then the 2015 we
don't want to repeat the same mistake by
making sure this one indeed is a robust
consultative process and that means
forming groups that are going getting
civil society involved making sure that
their workshops that regional
institutions will incorporate a
discussion on the post-2015 that Rio +20
on the sustainable development goals
have to be taking into account that g7
plus which involve fragile states and a
new deal will have to be taken into
account so that process is on and at the
end of the day it is hoped that the new
agenda will reflect it there are some
emerging consensus around certain things
like the continuation of the fight
against poverty ensuring women's and
empowerment education introducing new
things such as youth youth development
addressing climate change all of those
are things that are now being debated
and discussed but there is no agenda yet
that agenda still has to come after a
consultation global consultation in
which we can see where the threats of
consensus and in community of effort
begins to come together and that will
not happen a timeframe is short we have
to present a report to secretary-general
I join next year so he prints presents a
General Assembly in September but the
commitment to make it come from the
wishes of the people as strong and I
hope that it can be done
mine concluded bosses I started at 7:30
this morning with a meeting with
philanthropist I moved on to a meeting
on rural women empowerment I went on to
the corporate Council on Africa to talk
about investment and growth and are now
here with you and I'll ask you to please
let me go home
ladies and gentlemen please remain in
your seats as we escort the speaker out
of the building please remain in your
seats thank you